>> Greg: A MATH PROFESSOR AT
BROOKLYN COLLEGE CLAIMS
MERIT-BASED EDUCATION, REWARDS
LINKED TO HARD WORK AND TALENT
IS A TOOL OF EVIL WHITENESS.
IN AN ARTICLE, LAURIE RUBEL SAYS
COLORBLINDNESS HOLDS BACK
MINORITIES BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
ACCORDING TO CAMPUS REFORM, THE
TEACHER RECOMMENDS INJECTING
SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUES INTO
I CAME UP WITH AN EXAMPLE.
SALLY IS CARRYING SIX SKI MASKS
TO ENTITY FOR RALLY.
SHE AND QUARTERS -- ENCOUNTERS
FOUR EVIL WHITE MALE WHO STEALS
TWO.
HOW MANY DOES SHE HAVE LEFT?
ANSWER: YOU ARE RACIST.
EVEN SOCIAL JUSTICE MIGHT NOT BE
ENOUGH.
THEY THINK EFFORT LEADS TO
PROBLEM INTO A BIGGER ONE.
TO DEEM ACHIEVEMENT BASED REWARD
CAN'T DO WHAT OTHER KIDS CAN.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T THINK COLORBLINDNESS ARE
MERIT-BASED REWARDS HOLDS BACK
STUDENTS.
TEACHERS WHO SEEK TO -- IT'S NO
HELP FOR STUDENTS ONCE THEY HIT
THE REAL WORLD.
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
A RAISE.
FACTS HAVE NO FEELINGS.
THAT MATH IS SO SIMPLE EVEN I
CAN DO IT, AND I MAJORED IN
SLEEP.
DANA, MERITOCRACY IS RACIST.
>> Dana: WHO KNEW?
>> Greg: I DID.
>> Dana: CHANGING THE WORD
PROBLEM HELPS THE KID FIGURE OUT
THE ANSWER TO THE FACT PROBLEM,
WITH THE FACT IS, I DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT.
>> Jesse: MY THOUGHT IS THE
OPPOSITE OF MERITOCRACY IS
RACIST.
HERSHEY GRADE -- HOW DOES SHE
GRADE HER PAPERS?
IN SPORTS, MERITOCRACY WORKS IN
SPORTS.
GET THE NBA, IT IS MOSTLY
BLACKS.
THEY ARE THE BEST SCORES,
DEFENDERS.
PEOPLE IN WALL STREET, THEY
DON'T CARE WHAT COLOR YOU ARE AS
LONG AS YOU MAKE MONEY FOR THEM.
THEY WILL HIRE ANYBODY.
>> Greg: SURE PEOPLE ARE OFTEN
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST.
>> Jesse: IN THE NBA.
>> Greg: STUDY SHOW TALL
PEOPLE OFTEN GET HIGHER SALARIES
AND GET JOBS FASTER THAN SHORT
PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: I NEED A RAISE.
>> Juan: ALL OF THE PRESIDENTS
ARE TALL WHITE MAN EXCEPT FOR
OBAMA, AND HE'S A TALL BLACK GUY
OBAMA, AND HE'S A TALL BLACK GU
MERITOCRACY DIFFERS FROM MINE.
I THINK WHAT THEY SUGGESTED IS
IS THAT PEOPLE AREN'T TRYING
HARD ENOUGH OR DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SUCCEED AND OF COURSE
MIRRORED IN OUR COUNTRY,
ESPECIALLY IN EDUCATION, ACTs,
S.A.T.s.
AN ADDITIONAL SCREEN TO KEEP
NEWCOMERS OUT OF THE ELITES.
>> Greg: THAT WAS WHAT THE
S.A.T. WAS FAR?
>> Juan: INITIALLY.
HERE'S THE THING.
>> Greg: I'VE NEVER HEARD
THAT.
>> Juan: THE IMPACT IS ENOUGH
TO MAKE YOU CRAZY.
YOU HEAR FROM BLACK KIDS IT'S
ACTING WHITE IF YOU ARE VERY
AGGRESSIVE, DILIGENT STUDENT.
IT MAKES ME NUTS.
AT THE SAME TIME, YOU DON'T WANT
PEOPLE MAKING THE ASSUMPTION
DIFFICULTIES AT HOME, SCHOOL,
WHATEVER, AND CAN'T DO IT.
YOU WANT BOTH SIDES TO REPEAT
WHAT PRESIDENT BUSH SAID WHICH
AND WE SHOULDN'T LEAVE ANY
CHILDREN BEHIND.
YOU HAVE A CHILD.
SEE FIVE I DO, AND HE IS GOOD AT
MATH.
I FIND MATH HARD.
I WAS OUTSTANDING ALTHOUGH I
HAVE TO TO ALGEBRA.
INDECENT, THEN FORGET THE REST
OF IT.
>> Juan: OFTENTIMES THEY
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST WOMEN.
>> Kimberly: FINE.
IT'S WORKED OUT FANTASTICALLY.
SOMETIMES YOU'RE BETTER AT
CERTAIN THINGS.
THE WHOLE POINT IS TO LEARN AND
PUT IT IN A WAY THAT'S EASY TO
UNDERSTAND AND MAYBE PEOPLE ARE
DYSLEXIC OR HAVE LEARNING
PROBLEMS.
I GET IT BUT I'M NOT GOING TO GO
BACK AND TRY TO RETAKE THE
S.A.T.
>> Jesse: YOU WANT TO HAVE
UNIFORM STANDARDS FOR EVERYBODY,
OR ELSE YOU CAN'T JUDGE.
>> Kimberly: MY MATH ON THE
TRUMP SUPPORT.
MY MATH WAS BAD.
NOT MARRIED TO ROSEANNE BARR BUT
IS A REPUBLICAN.
TOM ARNOLD.
REMEMBER THAT, "MARRIED WITH
CHILDREN?"
>> Jesse: MY FAVORITE SHOW.